oleksiy rota says that if he were
American he'd vote for Trump possibly
Simotas a dairy farmer he produces
cheese beauty's produce the milk for my
cheese for my Russian parmesan my dear
he runs a successful business thanks
mainly to Western economic sanctions
against Russia the Russian state has
stepped in to support its farmers with
cheap loans so they can produce goods
that can't be imported but perhaps not
for much longer as a farmer I'm Pro
Trump I like his conservative stance
that is in favor of economic
protectionism all farmers all over the
world otherwise his life so my gut
feeling is pro Trump my mind tells me no
this I'm worried he'll lift the
sanctions against Russia not because
he's a friend of Russia because he wants
to sell American products and then
they'll flood our market with
competition from large foreign producers
demand for sea rotas cheese would
decline because it would become too
expensive for Russian consumers he'd
struggle to repay his loans worth
millions of euros and would go broke
few Russians worry about scenarios like
this one instead many in Moscow are
relieved that Donald Trump won the race
rather than Hillary Clinton many accused
Clinton of Russia bashing Trump in
contrast is regarded as pro-russian or
at least as someone who wants to do
business in Russia pictures showing
Trump with Russian pop stars have
recently surfaced rumor has it that
Trump loves all things Russian in
Moscow's wealthy rebuke our neighborhood
customers can pick up a unique piece of
bling a golden Trump phone telephone is
part of our presidential range
we also offer various Putin phones and
ones with other presidents as well we've
got all great leaders really past and
present and we want to express hope that
ties between our countries will improve
the trunk phone and Putin phone are
equally expensive both presidents are
equals if you will
here Kremlin loyalists teenagers are
practicing how they can back Trump with
his conservative values alongside Putin
these members of the Youth Organization
set meaning net in English also hope the
country's relations will improve we
second Putin in saying that Russia is
much more than matroyshka dolls of
balalaikas in bears is a sovereign actor
in global political economic and
cultural matters and Russia has a unique
set of interests and values that must be
respected if one is to form a
partnership with us Trump will usher in
a resurgence in global conservatism
while talk of European tolerance is
common brush of civilization built on
traditional values nowadays traditional
values are propagated all over the
country Russians should have children
attend church and follow traditional
gender roles rather than cherish
individualism and a diversity of
opinions another reason why progressives
dread Trump's assent Trump hasn't said a
single bad word about Putin even though
Russia retains political prisoners
opposition politician Boris Nemtsov was
killed tens of thousands of people were
killed in the Dunbar's because of
Newton's war a malaysian boeing' was
downed killing 300 passengers how's the
Russian opposition supposed to deal with
Trump will treat him as the leader of an
enemy state dairy farmer alexey low
table won't go that far
he still has hopes that trump won't
improve ties with russia overnight and
that he'll keep his economic sanctions
in place for another few years Trump a
lot as a person loved it if he were to
be russia's President Vladimir Putin of
course but he'll be the American
president which is why I'm worried about
my cheese business my farm and my cows
I'm responsible for them Trump could
destroy my livelihood
and so this Russian farmers fate is
intimately tied to the intricacies of
world politics and Trump's stance on
Russia